every woman who is successful regardless
of the field that she works in or
appears in
is deemed to be the exception that
proves the rule
and every time a woman in whatever field
fails
she is simply well
she's a woman ain't she
[Music]
to quote the glass ceiling may have been
cracked but it certainly hasn't been
brought down yet
[Music]
the options that were available to my
gender then were pretty much you were a
child and then you left school the next
big step for you was getting married
actually I think that has dramatically
changed over the quite a few decades but
we are still a really long way away from
genuine equality as far as gender is
concerned
[Music]
a central driving dramatic engine
of virtually every play was a male women
were still the adjunct it was virtually
unheard of for there to be a woman
director
but nobody ever commented on that
because that was the tradition that was
where everybody had grown up in it was
not exclusive to the theater it was the
whole of life
primary voices were always male I am
still stunned at the way contemporary
dramatists do not find
women interesting
when I first entered Parliament as a
member there was a strong sense I think
that I was some kind of Diva or but I
was a complete airhead I would fall flat
on my face or I would expect special
treatment none of that was true it was
pretty much a white middle-aged male
dominated chamber the egos that I saw
marching up and down those corridors
would not have been tolerated for 30
seconds in a professional theater I mean
somebody said to me how are you going to
manage in what is essentially a man's
club
and I said but that's been my experience
on my life
it's so hidden from one sense I think
every woman is well fitted
[Music]
the fact that it's a male didn't worry
me
as we get older those harsh definitions
of our gender begin to fracture
they begin to slip apart a bit they
become a bit foggy
those begin to change and I found that
very useful
every woman knows she's experienced it
in something I just didn't get a job
she's qualified for or sort of tried to
put her off whatever she wants to do we
read every year about these big guys in
the city and their bonuses with more
notes after them than a donut shop and
still not enough women on boards and
things of that nature they are provable
and definable
um but we can't delude ourselves to
think that what happens in the city
boardroom doesn't happen
in a little shop or you know what I mean
it's simply endemic
you have to keep pushing without it I
mean you have to keep banging the same
drum Mickey
you have to tediously say the same thing
over and over and over again I mean it's
kind of
well it's a cliches but it isn't really
a rule of thumb in the theater that you
have to say something three times before
an audience hears it
but certainly changing the actual
structure of societies
and
having it accepted as a norm
that women actually can do anything if
they are affording the same
opportunities the same inroads into
learning that is an automatic given to
the other gender
then we can achieve and we can work
together and we can make hopefully
a better world
but there are no silver bullets
it takes more than one campaign
it takes more than one argument
and it's hard but it can be done we have
seen improvements made where by no means
near the promised land but
we're quite way up the hill
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
Subscribe button and click the Bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video